If you had the option and did not watch Nickelodeon as a child, you missed out.
Television through the years shows have come and gone
But his fans look back on their favorites some pretty shocking theories have boiled to the surface
See what characters actually died who crossed over onto other shows and what shocking revelations may come from your favorite Nicktoons
Before you watch click subscribe you'll join the notification squad and be the first to know of new content also
Can you guess which movie is represented by these emoji stay tuned at the end to find out?
Timmy Turner is Danny Phantom growing up with fairy
Godparents is given Timmy Turner some great perks we followed his adventures through ten seasons of the hit Nick Toon Fairly
OddParents and even saw the addition of a third
Godparent by the name of poof Timmy can wish for anything he wants and gets to go on all sorts of adventures of course
Timmy's fun only last to the age of 13
That's when the godparents have to move on from their assignment this left lots of fans wondering about the future of Timmy
But the answer is clear according to a widespread
Theory upon turning 13 Timmy wishes to become a ghost fighting superhero
And his whole world is transformed into Danny Phantom
That's right a popular theory states that Danny Phantom and Timmy Turner are actually the same person
The characters have very similar looks and the same color eyes
supporting evidence can also be found through the show's supporting characters Chester looks like a younger version of -
AJ is a younger version of Tucker and Trixie is a younger version of Paulina the characters not only look alike
But they also have similar personality traits
Considering that both shows were created by Butch Hartman the connection makes more sense and is only even stronger
Spongebob is reborn first show that's been on for nearly 20 years and Counting SpongeBob SquarePants has gone through several
changes over this time one of the biggest differences between the
Personality and the way spongebob acts can be seen at the start of season five in this season spongebob appear much more
Childish he's not as intelligent as he once was
And he does a lot more immature things with his friends like Patrick the drastic change in character points to one theory stating that
Spongebob was actually reborn after dying and that his newborn younger self doesn't have the same maturity as his previous incarnation
Did wondering when spongebob died and was reborn?
It's all on film for you in the first spongebob squarepants feature-length film
Spongebob and patrick are captured and brought to a beach souvenir shop
They're put under a heated lamp at a table and dry out the movie shows a tear bring them back to life
But real-life sponges are actually asexual and can reproduce on their own spongebob didn't come back to life
He was merely
reborn again the younger and immature
Spongebob also explains why he didn't remain the manager of the Krusty Krab as seen at the end of the movie
The fake Pete one of the more quirky and bizarre shows to ever appear on
Nickelodeon was The Adventures of Pete and Pete the two brothers lived a strange life filled with
Superheroes ice cream men and some pretty crazy
scenarios involving
Friends and family things may just seem a little weirder when he consider a fan theory stating the younger Pete was actually a fictional
manifestation of the older Pete basically it says that Pete had schizophrenia
And he envisioned the younger Pete as a way to capture years of youthful adventures
He missed out on Pete would also
manifest other
Characters on the show like the strong man named Artie the theory has some evidence in the form of the way the characters act around
Pete also for the simple fact that his parents would name both children by the same name the mom on the show also has a
metal plate on her head
Which could have been the result of a condition passed down to the older Pete does the whole theory sound familiar?
It basically plays out like a child's version of Fight Club where Tyler Durden isn't a real character
But still has the ability to interact and communicate with the narrator of the story
Crazy Steve kidnapped Carly producer and writer Dan Schneider has spent years developing shows for Nickelodeon
He said several back-to-back hits starting with Drake and Josh
Transitioning to AI car and then eventually forming into crossover hits like
victorious and salmon cat there's one thing connecting the universe of all these shows and that's a character known as
Crazy steve played by Jerry Trainor crazy Steve made his debut and drake and josh is one of the movie theatre employees once
Icarly premiered the actor Jerry Trainor played Carly's older brother Spencer
but fans quickly strung a theory together making you question whether
Spencer is really Carly's brother at all the theory states that crazy Steve
eventually killed Drake and Josh while kidnapping their younger sibling Megan through manipulation and
Brainwashing crazy Steve moved Megan to Seattle forced her to change her name to Carly and the rest is history
The theory seemed a little far-fetched at first that is until a random episode of Sam and Kat showed crazy Steve in an insane
Asylum this helped make the final connection and revealed crazy steve was finally caught after Carly got away on the series finale of icarly
If Sam and Kat had continued to produce more episodes. We may have gotten more answers about the true story of crazy Steve
Drake and Josh the reality show every episode of Drake and Josh
Pretty much began the same way Drake and Josh would talk to the camera
Showcase their point of view and help set up the plot for the whole episode
While it appeared to have been done as a creative choice
Later clues from down the line may reveal that Drake and Josh was actually a show within a show
The reality show followed the characters lives as they dealt with their teenage years and their mixed family life
Some of the biggest clues to the reality show Theory actually come from other Nick shows on
Victorious multiple characters have referred to watching the show and on iCarly clips of the show have been shown
Pranks
one of the biggest clues comes from a character played by Yvette Nicole Brown
on Drake and Josh Brown played the movie theater manager named Helen Dubois on
Victorious the same
Character comes to take over as principal of Hollywood Arts High School if the characters on Victorious watched Drake and Josh and the same
Character shows up at their school
Then this is pretty much a confirmation that Drake and Josh was the reality show said in they're connected universes oh
Sure Mac
So great Steve's drug problem poor Blue's Clues
The preschool show we watched way beyond our
Preschool years has been under the microscope of rumors and theories for years
Some of the craziest rumors came when Steve left the show and was replaced by Joe
but people still can't coming up with theories about the adventures a grown man has with his puppy Blu as rumors of Steve's death and
Real life were proven to be false other
Rumors sparked up about the character and the stories he comes up with one of the more popular theories
Involves Steve taking drugs the characters use of heavy and hard drugs has created the whole
Alternate reality where blue and everything in his house comes to life how else would you explain?
Talking salt and pepper shakers who had a child together named paprika things seemed even more
drug-induced when Steve starts jumping into paintings and going on all sorts of crazy adventures
Right inside his own home these moments can all be seen as drug
Hallucinations for all we know Steve is just lounging in his big chair letting his mind run wild
You can only imagine the drugs and lifestyle the character into when he left the house to Joe and headed off to college
Timmy turner's
antidepressants The Fairly OddParents had ten seasons of happiness and adventures
But it didn't always start out this way timmy turner was not a happy child at the beginning
He had troubles at school was often neglected by his parents, and he was forced to deal with Vicky his horrible babysitter
According to a theory all of these factors. Led to depression to help with his depression Timmy didn't get the help of fairy godparents
But rather was prescribed
Antidepressants he manifested into his alternate view of godparents each godparent Timmy has could be broken down into different
Antidepressant medications the antidepressant Prozac is represented by Wanda Prozac is known for allowing a person to be calm and focused
Much like Wanda is in the series
Cosmo represents the antidepressant medication known as zoloft this works to make you more giddy and excited rather than depressed and
Represents exactly how Cosmo acts in the series the pills are taken and Timmy's room
Which just happens to be the place where the fairies appear anytime the fairies run out of magic or disappear?
It's essentially the pills wearing off and Timmy's depression starting to take hold again come to think of it
We're getting a little depressed just thinking about this theory
Jimmy neutrons government conspiracy
Jimmy Neutron is a boy genius who entertained Knick fans for over a decade
Looking back on the series there were some odd things
Involving the characters and the town of retro Ville a widespread theory about the show puts everything into a perspective easy to explain
Jimmy and the other children were genetically modified government experiments used to help with military research and inventions
Basically Jimmy's whole life is a big lie the town of retro Ville is a front with paid actors used to play
Citizens this is one of the reasons no one bats an eye when Jimmy flies around in a rocket or has some sort of crazy
weapon
This is also a reason why a number of Jimmy's inventions just happen to disappear once invented the government takes them for their own research
Development the theory is proven even further with the show's presence of area 86 the secret government
Facilities exist in retro Ville and are obviously the headquarters where Jimmy and all of his friends are tracked and researched
Jimmy's work and inventions have been influenced by several seemingly random events in the town
But maybe those were purposely created to get the new inventions the government needed
Are you afraid of the dark
Scariest ghosts one of Nickelodeon's greatest shows will always be are you afraid of the dark the anthology series?
Followed a group of friends known as the midnight society as they took turns telling scary stories around a campfire
Aliens clowns and witches were just a few of the tales keeping kids up late at night in the 90s and early
2000s the show touched on many different subjects, but one of the scariest aspects may have been the midnight society
Themselves a theory speculates that the midnight society was actually made up of the ghosts of teens who died young?
Breaking down the various events can help shed light on this eerie theory the characters only showed up at night
They were never seen in their everyday life
And they all seemed to come from different
Directions in the woods their parents never cared how late they stayed out and none of them really touched on lives
outside of their ghost story group when a new member joined the group they
Represented another tragic death of a teen when a member left the group they crossed over to the other side as the midnight society
represented a state of limbo
Until the teen ghosts can confront their darkest fears and sins now reliving the series just got a little scarier
definitely something else I
Felt like I was kissing my sister
nevermind
complete friendzone
Larissa explains it all to her children before Melissa Joan Hart wooed audiences with her witchy magic on Sabrina the Teenage Witch
she was making fans with her likeable character and family life on Clarissa explains it all the show lasted for five seasons on Nick and
The final episode left us with a fantasy glimpse at the future
But we never knew some of the future would become a reality in one of the more legitimate
theories found from Nick shows the 90s series may have a connection to the
2004 series entitled Ned's Declassified School Survival Guide on the show we're never introduced to Ned's parents
But we do learn that Ned's second surname is darling the same as Clarissa this could easily be brushed off as a random coincidence
but a further clue about Ned's father adds more to the
Connection in another episode Ned refers to his father as Sam
the name of klarissa's neighbor and love interest from the series this means that Ned could be the love child of Clarissa and Sam but
It's pretty clear that Sam isn't stepping up to be the father
He should be maybe he's too busy visiting other houses and climbing up windows with his trusty ladder of course the connection may seem legit
if you ignore the release of the official Clarissa novel where she's childless and
There you have it what theory do you believe the most are there any we missed?
What's your favorite Nick show let us know in the comments section below?
don't forget to like this video share it and subscribe to us on YouTube to stay up to date with our awesome videos and
the answer to the emoji quiz is
You